the cast of Gray's Anatomy truly feels
like a revolving door sometimes with
Ellen pompeo's Meredith gray holding
everything together majorino's Heather
Brooks came aboard in season nine right
after a big plane crash finale that
killed off a number of main characters
Brooks was an overly energetic
enthusiastic and bubbly character who
was mostly played for Laughs as a total
annoyance
I'm interrupting you guys were having a
moment or something the intern did have
a super sweet side as well as a
temporary romantic dallians with another
graze Mainstay Dr Alex karev but alas
majorino couldn't escape Shonda Rhimes
ax in Gray's anatomy's 10th season
Brooks was electrocuted during a storm
subsequently having to undergo brain
surgery to clear a hemorrhage she sadly
didn't make it and the other interns and
doctors realized how much of a joy she
truly was only after she was gone